a
rencontre de ces pilotes.
On vous offre en cadeau ce
magnifique reportage Catherine
François.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Simon Lebrun et
Pascal Desrochers contemplent
le fleuve Saint-Laurent.urent.u.
Ils attendent le MSC Donata,
un porte-conteneur
de la compagnie maritime MSC,
qu'ils vont piloter
jusqu'au port de Montréal.
Il est 8 h 30 du matin,
le navire passe soe passe soe pt
de Trois-Rivières.
C'est le moment d'embarquer
sur le porte-conteneur
qui poursuit sa route
au milieu du fleuve,
et de grimper jusqu'à
la passerelle, la salle
de commande du bateau.
Pour les deux pilotes,
c'est leur bureau.
SIMON LEBRUN, pilote maritime,
Corp. pilotes St-Laurent Central
- Le pilote maritime est
un expert ou une experte locale
qui se joint à l'équipe
de passerelle dont fait partie
le capitaine, afin de les aider
à mener le navire à bon port.
Il ne réside pas à bord,
il ne fait pas de l'équipage
permanent.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Chaque bateau commercial
qui navigue sur le fleuve
Saint-Laurent entre les
Escoumins et les Grands Lacs,
est manoeuvré par des pilotes :
ils sont 230 à assurer
les différents tronçons
qui sectionnent le fleuve.
La Corporation des pilotes
du Saint-Laurent Central,
fondée en 1873, rassemble
les 126 pilotes qui naviguent
entre Québec et Montréal.
- Two-zero-eight, please.
- Simon et Pascal font
les allers-retours
Trois-Rivières-Montréal :
quelques 120 kilomètres et
une soixantaine de courbes à
faire prendre à ces mastodontes
de la mer.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le MSC Donata mesure 255 mètres
de long par 32 de large.
Il pèse 68 000 tonnes. C'est
parmi les plus gros navires que
l'on peut croiser sur le fleuve.
- Le chenal dragué, lui, c'est
245 mètres. Il y a certains
endroits où on a un chenal
naturel qui va s'élargir.
- Devenir pilote sur le fleuve
est un long processus :
quatre ans d'études à l'Institut
maritime du Québec, à Rimouski,
puis au moins cinq ans
de navigation partout dans
le monde pour devenir capitaine,
et deux autres années
de formation pour devenir pilote
et gravir les échelons
par la suite.
- On dit que pour former
un pilote qui pourra piloter
tous les navires sur le fleuve
Saint-Laurent, ça prend
presque dix ans à partir
du moment où on devient
apprenti pilote jusqu'à temps
où on a la formation nécessaire
pour piloter un navire
comme celui sur lequel
on est aujourd'hui.
PASCAL DESROCHERS, prés.
et pilote maritime, CPSLC
- Donc on est rendu, là,
à 17 à 20 années au total
pour prendre quelqu'un qui
déciderait de faire carrière
dans ce domaine-là.
- La Corporation doit d'ailleurs
gérer l'enjeu de la relève, car
beaucoup de pilotes ont pris,
ou vont prochainement prendre,
leur retraite.
Un métier très bien payé,
en moyenne 300 000 dollars
par an, mais très stressant
et exigeant : les pilotes
travaillent de jour comme
de nuit, 24 heures sur 24,
365 jours par an, et ont
4 heures d'avis avant
de connaître leur affectation.
- Donc, la gestion
de notre sommeil et de notre
repos... est un défi personnel
qu'il faut bien gérer.
- Tous les ans, 6000 navires
naviguent sur le fleuve Saint-
Laurent et les pilotes de
la Corporation des pilotes
du Saint-Laurent Central
font 14 000 affectations
annuellement. Autrement dit,
toutes les 40 minutes,
jour et nuit, un pilote
embarque sur un navire
entre Québec et Montréal.
Et ces pilotes sont un maillon
central dans la chaîne
de l'économie canadienne.
- C'est l'aorte économique
du Québec et d'une grande partie
du Canada, c'est le fleuve
Saint-Laurent. 80 % de ce qui
se ramasse sur les tablettes
des commerces ont transité par
le fleuve. C'est des milliards
dans l'économie canadienne qui
transitent sur le fleuve. Alors,
c'est une artère économique
d'une première importance.
- Notre principal outil
pour naviguer dans ce secteur,
ce sont les radars.
- Côté sécurité, rien n'est
laissé au hasard : en plus
des instruments de navigation
qui sont sur les navires,
les pilotes apportent leurs GPS
et carte électronique afin de
coupler les données et vérifier
qu'il n'y a pas d'erreur,
une démarche indispensable quand
il n'y a pas de visibilité.
- Notre bilan de sécurité,
c'est : 99,95 % des transits
se font sans aucun incident.
- C'est un peu ça qui nous
hante, entre guillemets,
c'est qu'on ait un bris
mécanique dans des endroits
plus délicats ou lorsqu'on
rencontre un autre navire,
si on avait une panne machine.
- Si les instruments de
navigation sont indispensables
au pilotage, ainsi que
les bouées et les repères
alignés tout le long du chenal,
l'outil le plus précieux
du pilote, ce sont ses yeux.
- Si je mets un clocher
d'église en ligne avec le coin
d'une maison, ça me donne
une ligne de positionnement.
Il ne peut pas y avoir d'erreur,
c'est une ligne qui est
parfaite.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La navigation hivernale
est un défi supplémentaire
pour les pilotes, avec la brume,
les tempêtes de neige,
les glaces sur le fleuve.
D'où l'importance d'avoir
ces experts à la barre sur
ce fleuve réputé capricieux.
Ils sont d'ailleurs assignés
à un seul tronçon durant
toute leur carrière.
- C'est la nature même
du travail du pilote.
C'est de connaître par coeur
un tronçon particulier.
On est vraiment un expert
de la navigation locale.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il est près de 18 h quand
le MSC Donata accoste enfin
au quai du port de Montréal.
(musique angoissante)
C'est mission accomplie
pour Simon et Pascal...
jusqu'au prochain navire.